how many employees are you hey so are
you any worried about the dynamic
changes
I have some insight I really do this is
this is really my wheelhouse
this will ultimately be the somebody
asked me earlier today when I'm writing
my HR book I'm not ready to but this
will be the best thing I'll ever put out
into the world I know that effect you're
looking at an HR driven CEO I'm Labor
media has gone from twenty to four
hundred employees in the last thirty
months and I'm the only person in the HR
department so you've stepped in [ __ ] I
got a lot of insights here's the number
one thing I'll tell you every company
lies about how much they care about the
customer and how much they care about
their employees it's really easy to say
I care about customers and my employees
that was easy right I think of it like
parenting all these parents come to me
like Oh Gary like all this technology is
so bad I don't want my kid on the iPad
for seven hours a day like well then
don't let them write so I may be one
huge piece advice if you truly care
about the question you just asked me put
in the work right for example back to
the earlier joke I desperately want a
six-pack right I don't have one I know
how to do it I know the exercises I know
the food that I need to eat I can Google
everything I need in 20 seconds to
figure out how to get a six pack but I
don't have one because I didn't put in
the work
I am busy as [ __ ] I blew away my friends
that were with me today because they saw
that I got a thousand text messages in
the six hours I was hanging out with
them that's busy right and yet I spend
between 3 & 6 hours a day on HR now you
and I are the same business you know
what I can do in those 46
hours from getting incremental scope
going in getting new business right I
really care about culture I really care
about my cut cut my employees and look I
start with my voice I tell my my uh I
tell my customers the Pepsi's and G's
and dozen I tell them I care about my
employees first I care about your
customers on the platforms that we
create for second and then I care about
you and I and the best part is we
execute against that and so the reason I
do it by the way I'm not mother Teresa I
do it because I know another one
vaynermedia forever and if I wanted to
do with Wine Library then I need to
build a family and you know how you bone
family you listen and so the reason
takes me three to four hours a day your
biggest problem is you need and look you
can have this problem at eight you don't
need the opinion you need to know what
all of those eight people want in their
lives I spend all my life basically it
feels like trying to build trust with my
employees so that they'll tell me the
truth of what they actually want to
happen and I'm agenda agnostic I don't
care what you want I don't care if you
wanna make five hundred thousand dollars
a year and not work that much cool you
know I don't care if you want to steal
seven of my employees and then start
your own agency cool I'm not joking I
don't care if you want to be the CEO I
don't care if you want to learn
everything you can for me and then go
into a startup and say you work with me
I do not care
just tell me so that we can map it
together so if you want to address it
I recommend you to a whole lot of
listening